[Music]
velvet buzzsaw is a stab at the art
world from the creative team that
brought you Nightcrawler throughout this
video I'll be discussing everything that
you need to know about the movie and its
ending this picture perfect brush with
death breakdown will contain spoilers so
if you don't want to know anything about
the movie then I highly suggest that you
turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to after an outstanding animated
intro we follow more for van der Walt an
art critic with a taste for pieces as
snazzy as his name he is fascinated by
an interactive item called the sphere
that attempts to touch upon the sense of
desire fear sex and more tapping into
the onlookers psyche in certain ways
that showcases their true inner self
this ties into the overall narrative of
the film in which the majority of the
pieces eventually end up attacking those
from the art world in ironic ways that
showcase the darkest parts of themselves
in the film the art world is described
as a safari that has just opened to find
the next thing and eat it and this
definitely reflects in the works that
end up hunting down those that become
attached to the pieces anyway after the
girl at morph is having an affair with
Josefina who was on the rebound from her
cheating ex discovers her neighbour has
committed suicide the outstanding pieces
that are discovered within his apartment
really set the art world on fire in more
ways than one the work of artists
normally goes up in value after their
death
as was the case with van Gogh and
Josefina's neighbor metal DS is no
different the artist literally put his
blood sweat and tears into the pieces
and in his death he ends up haunting
them petrol was abused as a child and
tried to burn his family in their home
due to this this of course is mirrored
in the work that he attempted to burn
before his death and showcases that he
was trying to rid the world of
evil throughout the film barrels ghost
tries to burn his work at every
opportunity but this has foiled several
times his work finds the appreciation
that he never got in life and is put on
display for the world to see Josefina
fearing for her job and future in the
art industry decides to greedily claim
the artist as her client and says it's
merely something that she found in the
dumpster through the desire to showcase
the work greed and pressure from her
peers they go on display after this the
deaths come thick and fast a staff
member who is accused of groping women
is grabbed by a bunch of ravenous
monkeys a snobby awed agent is hanging
much in the same way he hangs his pieces
and a woman who wants to strong-arm art
galleries into displaying her pieces
gets hers well cut off hilariously the
last death is so ambiguous that many
think it is part of the collection in
addition to this morph is put into a
room where he begins to criticize
himself and this causes him to break
down it becomes clear that something is
out to get the art curators that now
goes far beyond the work of Dees morph
attempts to write a piece that exposes
this however Josefina
and her boss red aura pre-emptive and
sell as much D's as they can before the
bad word gets out morph releases the
article and this puts him into conflict
with Josefina but that doesn't stop the
work from hunting down those who
attempted to profit from it from R
Edoras assistant Coco morph learns that
red aura has been getting advanced
warnings on his positive reviews before
they are printed so that she can buy the
work before its release and sell out a
higher price in the meantime Josefina is
blocked from returning home by a car and
goes to weigh in the gallery where we
discover that morph is attempting to get
rid of the work Worf is killed by a
mechanical robot on crutches and
Josefina is swarmed by paint leaking
into her eyeballs veins and more before
she is permanently imprisoned in a
graffiti piece that means she will
always be with her recently departed
lover red aura preemptive as always
attempts to get rid of the pieces before
they can get her however it is too
little too late and the titular velvet
buzzsaw tattoo on her neck spins up
killing her in the process in the end we
see deesis work being sold to the masses
on street corners by the homeless which
of course ties into the homeless exhibit
from earlier
film ultimately there is a lot to take
from this those that attempt it to
profit from Jesus death ended up facing
horrific ones themselves and this is as
much a story about materialism as it is
a horror the things you own ultimately
end up owning you and what you put into
the world will always come back to haunt
you in more ways than one
we see John Malkovich's character
gleefully drawing circles in the sand at
the end because he believed that art was
for expression and not profit similar to
this Josefina's final boyfriend felt
this and neither were affected by the
paintings all those who ended up dead
were trying to profit from the work
rather than allow it to be seen so we
can imagine that the pieces at the end
will not go on to kill their owners to
me this is confirmed by the sunset which
is shown and it's clearly a lot more of
a happier piece from these perhaps
symbolizing that his work is now
transformed into beauty instead of death
and despair overall I did have a lot of
fun with the film and it really hammered
home to me that all should be for
everyone rather than those who deem it
their property of course I'd love to
hear your thoughts on velvet buzzsaw and
what you took from its ending if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my
non-spoiler review on the film which
should be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are heavy into
horror so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]